away from the tumult of westminster and
into the comparative political calm of a
european war zone
here the prime minister is undeniably a
popular figure he's seen as a steadfast
ally
he offered a gift a book about the queen
and then promised enduring support for
the host nation
we will continue
as we have
from the beginning to provide the
military equipment that you need and now
of course the training that may be
necessary to go with that
with that new equipment
so that you the ukrainian people the
ukrainian armed forces
will be able to do what i believe
ukrainians
yearn
to do
and that is to expel
the aggressor from ukraine
from the ukrainian president the warmest
of thanks britain endorsed
this is your
second visit boris to kiev after the uh
after 24th of february the beginning of
the full scale invasion by the russian
federation to our soil
and i'm grateful to you for this
attention to our country uh to all our
people to our country and to your
leadership and the unparalleled support
by the united kingdom to ukraine
kyiv has been the heart of a diplomatic
swirl recently the leaders of france
germany italy and romania had all come
here the day before pledging to support
ukraine's bid to join the european union
and now endorsement of that from the
very top of the eu
adamant that ukraine should be given
official candidate status
we have one clear message
and that is yes
ukraine deserves european perspective
yes ukraine should be welcomed as a
candidate country
this is on the understanding that good
work has been done has been done
but important work also remains to be
done
back in kiev president and prime
minister went for a stroll through the
streets of the ukrainian capital they do
appear easy in each other's company this
is a city now full of somber reminders
of conflict but it's also a showcase for
the potent power of resistance
against all odds ukraine aspires to a
brighter future
adam parsons sky news